un enfant de 12 ans séquestré violé
asphyxié tué par une personne en
situation irrégulière et expulsable
depuis le 30 septembre 2022 ça vous
dirait de faire votre boulot
voilà la question est assez cash c'est
ce qui va se passer ce soir qu'est-ce
que vous répondez à ça monsieur ministre
d'abord je veux dire que personne peut
se mettre à la place des parents de Lola
d'abord une enfant violet et tué je
pense que tout le monde quand on est
père de famille comme je suis j'ai deux
enfants
pensent que c'est ce qu'elle puisse
ignoble
et à ce monsieur et à tous ceux qui se
posent la question moi je comprends leur
colère je veux aussi dire que je veux
aussi les persuader que moi je rentre
pas le soir où je vais pas le matin en
me disant tiens je fais un boulot comme
les autres puis qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui l'enfant s'est fait
tuer ça me fait rien je fais de la
politique pour éviter ça parfois on a
des échecs et à chaque fois qu'il y a la
mort de quelqu'un à chaque fois qu'elle
assassinat d'enfant et un échec de la
politique qui a un échec de la société
il y a un échec de la politique
évidemment et mise intérieure est
responsable de ce qui se passe dans le
pays mais je veux vraiment persuader les
uns les autres qu'on fait au mieux on
est peut-être pas les meilleurs ça c'est
aux électeurs de le juger aux élections
mais on fait au mieux ça me touche
autant plus que moi j'ai connu un drame
familial de perdre un enfant le fils de
ma sœur qui est mort assassiné aussi
dans des conditions extrêmement
extrêmement ignoble et que je sais ce
que ça fait comme dévastation dans une
famille
je sais que les parents ne sont plus
jamais comme avant et il y a pas d'eau
qui peuvent résumer la détresse que ça
peut porter alors on essaie de faire ce
qu'on peut
il y a une procédure judiciaire moi je
j'ai du mal à comprendre aujourd'hui
exactement les motifs qui ont poussé
manifestement cette dame qui aurait
reconnu je lis la presse comme vous il y
a un secret d'instruction d'avoir
assassiné violet cet enfant c'est très
très difficile à comprendre une jeune
femme qui a moins de 25 ans qui n'est
pas connu des services de police qui
manifestement n'était pas connu pour
avoir des maladies psychiatriques non
plus qui fait ses horreurs
ensuite il y a une autre question qui
est celle d'être étrangers mais c'est ça
c'est ça mais moi je vois la meurtrière
moi je vois pas à l'étranger je vois
d'abord la meurtrière ce qui concerne
l'enquête elle a été très très vite les
services de police sont très bien fait
leur travail ils ont très bien fait leur
travail les services de police tout le
monde en convient après ce qui vous est
reproché et c'est ce que vous reproche
aussi qui est dans le public retraitée
il y a aussi il est là merci vous pouvez
vous lever merci aussi d'être avec nous
retraités vous avez 74 ans vous dites
que vous avez le cœur déchiré comme tous
les Français par la mort de Lola et ça
vous empêche même de dormir la nuit
le ministre bonsoir bonsoir Monsieur
avant de vous exposer mes propos
permettez-moi de vous exprimer toute ma
gratitude pour le travail que vous
faites vous êtes un homme de terrain
vous l'avez montré pendant les vacances
alors que d'autres pardonnez-moi de le
dire ce doré au soleil vous avez pris
votre bâton de pèlerins et vous avez
sillonné toute la France et vous avez
fait face aux événements et pour cela je
permettais au du haut de mes 74 ans de
vous présenter ma différence pour votre
titre pour votre fonction et également
pour votre travail ceci dit Monsieur le
Ministre comment pouvons-nous résoudre
un problème si on ne le définit pas
aussi
ce massacre ce traumatisme qui a saisi
toute la France
suite à un assassinat
dont nous n'avons même pas les termes en
français
tout notre langue est riche mais elle
n'a pas les termes pour définir la perte
d'un enfant cette horreur ni le calvaire
de ses parents
comme si les attentats que nous avons
suivi jusqu'à présent les attentats
terroristes ne suffisait pas pour pour
la France qui souffre il fallait que
l'horreur dépasse un stade et
inimaginable
je sais Monsieur le Ministre
que vous avez
aussi
votre comment dire
votre émotion vous la contrôlez
aujourd'hui moi il m'est difficile de la
contrôler je suis en colère et pourquoi
je suis en colère je me pose la question
je suis un grand-père je suis un père
qu'est-ce que nous allons laisser à nos
enfants dans une dans une société qui
est en train de de
on dirait que nous sommes des zombies
bien dans le micro aussi merci on dirait
que nous sommes des zombies on est en
train de nous tuer de nous assassiner
de décapiter des professeurs
de menacer de tabasser des enfants quand
ils sortent des lycées jusqu'à quand ça
va continuer jusqu'à quand nous allons
subir l'espace le mal que des étrangers
en situation irrégulière font subir aux
français jusqu'à quand on nous sommes
obligés à un moment de se poser la
question
alors ensuite je peux continuer allez-y
j'ai l'impression que c'est comme s'il y
avait une OPA contre la société
française
où on voit des des agressions constantes
et continuent comme si le terrorisme que
nous avons suivi n'était pas suffisant
et j'attire votre attention sur ce fait
parce que c'est peut-être un fait de
terrorisme interne c'est possible je
n'en sais rien en tout cas moi je ne le
comprends pas on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas on ne peut pas le comprendre
le sang était versé
combien de sang sera versé monsieur le
ministre sur l'hôtel de certaines
négligences de de de de
certains manque de contrôle qui ont
peut-être causé la mort de cette petite
fille et ainsi que d'autres je ne veux
pas non plus monopoliser la parole mais
si je pouvais je vous aurais lu ne
serait-ce que pour rappeler leur mémoire
le nombre de personnes qui ont été
assassinées en France depuis plusieurs
années et vous le savez mieux que
quiconque parce que vous êtes le premier
informé merci aujourd'hui
je termine aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre des parents ont perdu un enfant
on tirait un enfant c'est la chose la
plus pire qu'il y a la question en fin
de compte que faisait cette personne en
France
est-ce qu'il y a eu des contrôles on
voudrait on voudrait que vous nous
expliquiez
que nous comprenions ce qui s'est passé
nous sommes vos administrés si on ne
peut pas vous poser des questions ou si
on n'a pas l'occasion de poser à qui
nous allons le poser je vous remercie
monsieur le merci merci aussi pour votre
exposé pour votre question c'est une
question que énormément de
téléspectateurs se pose monsieur le
ministre je le vois sur les réseaux
c'est la question qui revient en premier
pourquoi cette personne était sur le
territoire c'est la question de Monsieur
Malka
et tous les jours sur mon bureau
j'allais dire tous les nuits sur mon
bureau vous savez mes intérieurs quand
ils se lève le matin il a quatre
dossiers c'est tous les faits divers de
la zone gendarmerie de la zone police à
Paris et des services secrets qu'on
appelle la DGSI et des horreurs monsieur
depuis 2 ans et demi quasiment que je
suis intérieur j'envoie tous les jours
vous envoyer plus qu'avant
parce que nous on a le sentiment écoutez
moi je vais vous dire quelque chose j'ai
déjà beaucoup plus j'ai été maire de de
Tourcoing populaire je voyais déjà
beaucoup de choses horribles parce que
quand on émet on est directement en
contact avec le plus beau et le plus
terrible de ce qui se passe dans sa
commune
depuis deux ans et demi je vois le même
nombre d'heures parce que évidemment ce
qui me remonte c'est les hors les plus
horribles pardon de cette expression
et à ceux qui prennent médiatiquement et
puis à ceux qui prennent pas
médiatiquement il y a malheureusement
plein de faits divers qui voudraient
tous vous bousculer qui vous choquez et
puis pour plein de raisons les médias
n'en parlent pas c'est encore plus
inquiétant ce que vous dites oui mais
c'est la vérité de ce qui se passe si à
peu près un petit millier d'homicides de
meurtres d'assassinat par an ça fait 10
ans qui a à peu près 900 homicides par
an et tout le monde connaît les
attentats qu'on a connu puis il y a tous
ceux qu'on a déjoué aussi moi j'aime
tous les matins des fiches qui
expliquent comment on a évité ça
évidemment c'est une excuse pas quand ça
arrive on est apparemment vous parler
des attentats monsieur on a des jouets
39 attentats depuis que nous sommes en
responsabilité avec les Modus opérandir
on se dit à chaque fois qu'est-ce que ce
serait si c'est rentré dans un bar
homosexuel dans un lieu juif dans une
mosquée dans dans une école on a évité
ça en France voilà
et donc je me pose les mêmes questions
que vous monsieur voilà et moi je veux
dire que je fais pas tout bien je j'ai
sans doute fait des erreurs je ferai
sans doute encore de ma des erreurs mais
j'essaye et d'abord en tout cas je me
vois pas la face quand j'étais Noémie à
l'intérieur un mois après j'ai dit qu'il
y avait un ours sauvagement dans notre
pays tout le monde est tombé dessus et
le droit à tous les articles Dorman
exagère et court après le Front national
il court avec moi justement je dis les
mots sur les choses parce que c'est ce
que vous ressentez c'est ce qui
ressentent tous les Français rien de
pire quelqu'un qui va avoir son médecin
et lui je suis malade vous n'êtes pas
malade c'est un sentiment d'être malade
je pense que ça ça rend fou les gens
parce que l'impression que si on connaît
pas la maladie on peut pas donner
l'ordonnance qui permet de réparer cette
maladie moi je pense qu'un non
sauvagement de la société que les crimes
sont plus violents de plus en plus forts
dans la gevre dans l'object on le voit
bien les couteaux par exemple le nombre
de coups de couteau qui se donne la
violence personne et que on doit le
constater voilà et après j'ai dit une
deuxième chose j'ai dit qu'une partie
pas tout pas tout une partie de la
délinquance était le fait d'étranger
notamment étrangers en situation
irrégulière là aussi on m'a beaucoup
critiqué j'ai fait cet été vous parliez
de cet été on m'a aussi oui au gémonie
mais c'est une réalité je veux aussi
vous dire que l'immense majorité des
étrangers qui sont sur le sol national
se comportent extrêmement
étaient pas français donc j'ai pas moi
qui vais faire ce genre de de procès il
respectait la République et ils ont
enseigné je crois leurs enfants leurs
petits-enfants le respect de la
République la principale suspecte donc
Dabia une SDF de 24 ans quasi judiciaire
vierge de nationalité algérienne elle
était en situation irrégulière en France
elle était entrée légalement dans le
pays en 2016 avec un titre de séjour
étudiant elle a passé un cap c'est ça
[Musique]
pourquoi il est encore là alors il y en
a malheureusement
quelques-uns comme des périodes comme
cette personne qui sont en France
rentrer régulièrement et il y a plein de
gens qui me demandent des visas aussi
moi je ressens plein de lettres
d'habitants de tous les habitants qui me
disent je connais ma cousine j'ai ma
grand-mère j'ai mon frère donc il y a
des gens qui demandent des visa pour
venir en France quel que soit ces
visages regroupement familial pour le
travail pour les études
deuxième sujet il faut que le pays qui
est le pays de la nationalité accueille
ces personnes parce que quand vous serez
si un jour vous êtes ministre de
l'Intérieur vous aurez ce problème là
vous avez quelqu'un qui n'est pas
l'ordre du jour non mais c'est ton
jamais
on échangera non mais
c'est très sérieux ce que je dis parce
que vous aussi comprendre ça monsieur et
c'est le cas de tous les pays en Europe
et j'ai publié sur les réseaux sociaux
dont je parle les comparaisons avec les
autres pays d'Europe la France et le
pays qui expliquent le plus de personnes
en Europe plus que l'Allemagne puisque
l'Italie plus que l'Angleterre plus que
l'Espagne mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
quand on expulse quelqu'un il faut que
le pays d'accueil l'accueil alors vous
avez deux types de problèmes d'abord il
y a le pays avec lequel on a pas de
relation diplomatique l'Afghanistan on a
beaucoup d'avant sur le territoire
national on a beaucoup de Syriens sur le
territoire national il y a une dictature
Bachar el-Assad il y a une dictature de
taliban on ne on n'a pas de
d'ambassadeurs on n'a pas de liaison
aérienne je ne peux pas prendre
quelqu'un on le mette de force dans un
avion et le jeter au-dessus du de
l'Afghanistan ou de la Syrie premier
problème et nous avons des personnes qui
a une organisation de série qui
commettent des actes ignobles et ça
c'est un premier problème je vous
l'expliquer aux Français après il y a un
débat démocratique qui consiste est-ce
que quand même on expulse ces personnes
en Afghanistan et qu'on a des liens avec
les talibans ou pas première question
que se pose un état deuxième question
quand on a des relations diplomatiques
avec des états les États du Maghreb par
exemple mais pas simplement il faut que
le pays accepte parce que vous ne pouvez
pas de force mettre quelqu'un dans un
avion le faire atterrir dans la capitale
x le faire descendre et ça se passe
comme ça et puis c'est tout évidemment
il faut qu'il que le pays qui accueille
fait des laisser passer consulaires moi
je vais vous dire quelque chose moi je
suis ministre qui refuse que des
Français reviennent en France quand un
État étranger monsieur m'appelle elle me
dit vous avez un violeur un tueur un
pilleur qui a fait 15 ans de prison chez
moi dans le pays y je vais vous renvoyer
parce qu'il est français moi avant de
dire oui je mets du temps
quand vous avez appris le drame qui
s'est passé
et la mort de Lola quelle a été votre
réaction c'est ça les Français veulent
savoir vous avez eu la même réaction que
certainement la première chose que je
fais c'est que je demande comment
j'essaie de demander comment ça s'est
passé et surtout est-ce qu'on a
interpellé les auteurs parce que il y a
encore ça pire que après quand on vous a
dit que c'était une personne qui était
en situation irrégulière Vous êtes dit
quoi vous êtes dit on a on a merdé vous
êtes dit dans un bon c'est on aurait on
n'a pas on aurait pas pu faire autrement
mais c'est un échec à chaque fois chaque
fois qu'il y a un meurtre à chaque fois
qu'il y a quelqu'un qui est déclaré fou
et qui commet un acte
terroriste ou un acte contre un enfant
ou contre une personne on se dit c'est
un échec on aurait dû mettre en hôpital
psychiatrique on aurait dû trouver les
moyens de faire évidemment à chaque fois
que je vois un meurtre sur mon bureau je
me dis qu'on a on a loupé quelque chose
je dors pas tranquille monsieur avec ce
genre de choses après je vais vous dire
Monsieur juste un point la première
chose que j'ai fait lorsque j'ai entendu
évoqué cette histoire par les services
de police
ma première demande c'était qu'il
fallait arrêter et meurtrier présumé
parce que il est très vite le pire
aurait été que cette dame soit en
liberté commettre d'autres atrocités
donc elle a été arrêtée moi je vais
remercier les services de police d'après
préfecture de police de Paris de l'avoir
fait en quelques heures après
qu'on pense à sa famille soir on se dit
c'est c'est dramatique
la deuxième chose que je me dis monsieur
c'est effectivement c'est j'essaye de
comprendre ce qui a merdé
je vois bien qu'à la question de la
situation est régulière maintenant je
vais vous dire et il y a des gens très
très honnêtes qui l'ont dit Rachida Dati
qui n'est partage pas la même opinion
sur le gouvernement a dit on n'aurait
pas pu éviter ce drame je sais pas si on
n'aurait pas pu éviter ce drame mais
elle n'était pas connu des services de
police moi je vais vous dire aujourd'hui
dans les centres de rétention
administratifs les endroits où on place
ces étrangers enfermés en attendant
qu'on les expulse aujourd'hui 90% des
personnes qui sont dedans c'est des gens
qui ont commis des actes des crimes ou
des délits
parce que ce qui est important c'est de
mettre les multi récidivistes et
récidivistes les gens vont commis des
crimes déjà dans des centres de
rétention pour pas qu'ils soient libérés
en attendant pour les expulses et on
arrive de plus en plus à expulser pas
totalement mais de plus en plus c'est
pour ça qu'on fait des voyages à
l'international aussi on y fait on fait
pas ça que pour partager des repas avec
les dirigeants de ces pays moi je vais
un peu partout pour essayer de dire à
mes homologues on doit avoir des
relations qui sont fondées sur des
relations d'égalité ou de décompenses
qui se passe en France vous avez des
ressortissants qui sont très
régulièrement dans notre pays et si vous
les reprenez pas ça sachez prenez
l'exemple de certains pays du Maghreb
vous pouvez pas la fois dans les médias
si je peux me permettre dire quelques
pays du Maghreb sont pas contents parce
qu'on leur donne des vitres pas de visa
et ma grand-mère peut pas venir pour le
mariage mon oncle peut pas venir pour
faire ses études et puis quand il y a
des étrangers en situation irrégulières
qui sont en France pourquoi vous n'avez
pas expulsés c'est un c'est un tout si
on donne pas de visa c'est parce qu'ils
reprennent pas leur ressortissant
monsieur le ministre ça veut dire que ce
drame on aurait pas pu l'éviter pour
vous
objectivement trop tôt pour le dire il y
a une enquête judiciaire d'abord moi
vous dites monsieur vous avez fait le
parallèle avec les attentats terroristes
je comprends votre émotion je ne le
ferai pas je n'en sais rien aujourd'hui
je vous dis en toute vérité je n'en sais
rien les juges vont faire leur travail
est-ce que c'est quel est les motifs qui
poussent une jeune femme de moins de 25
ans de prendre une jeune fille qui
manifestant ne connaissait pas
de 11 ans pour la violer la torturer la
séquestrer puis la découper
ça devrait quand même nous frapper tous
je ne connais pas ces motifs selon les
motifs et selon l'enquête judiciaire que
fera juge on en tira toutes les
conclusions s'il y a des questions
particulières qu'il faut pour se
remettre en cause je le ferai bien
évidemment moi mon mon souci premier
monsieur c'est d'éviter ça la prochaine
fois alors et tous les jours je me dis
ça voilà j'ai tous les jours je me dis
pourquoi qu'est-ce que j'aurais pu faire
de mieux avec les services qui
m'accompagnent pour éviter ça